in 2015 i went to new york to
participate in a conference that is
organized there i was in queens a
neighborhood of new york in a store and
suddenly i realized that
everyone spoke only spanish and all those
things were in spanish that  the radio
was in spanish and the
dog had to speak to me in spanish and i
realized at this precise moment i already
knew it but i realized it i saw it with my own
eyes that spanish is a world language
nowadays learning spanish is like
learning  English or Chinese is an
investment for your life because surely you
are going to speak Spanish with someone in
the world. Hello, I am
Luca from Luca Lampariello dotcom and today I am going to
talk about how I have learned this
wonderful language that is
Spanish and  the lessons I have learned
in the process
when I started learning Spanish at the
age of 19 I realized that I had
found only one resource and I had no
internet I am old and this was my luck
I was very lucky because of  that this
allowed me to focus
only on this resource and develop what
I call my linguistic nucleus since we
are here I am going to teach you what I have
here I am going to teach this wonderful
course called the agostini course
but the most important thing is not  it is so much the
course itself that it is a great course
with films with literature it is the
fact that I have used only this course and
then I have advanced and once I have
developed this linguistic core
then I have used another and this is very
important today  we have too many
things we have this we have in the we have
an app we have is is too much it's called
the paradox of choice we have
too many things and we are confused
so even if you have internet even if you
have a lot of resources use
only one especially at first
because this is going to do  a big
difference
[Music
] Spanish or Castilian is spoken in
a lot of countries more than 20 countries in
the world from Mexico to Spain  paña from
argentina nicaragua this is fantastic
but at the same time it means that
you have a lot of different accents and
when you want to learn a language with
spanish you tell yourself which accent I am going to
learn it is a question that many of
my students ask me however if
you are american  it is more probable that you
want to learn with an accent from mexico
from argentina from peru because my
experience as you were saying
before when I was in new york' is
that there are a lot of latin americans
those are the accents that are most spoken
in the usa so a  practical advice
for developing a coherent system of
sounds an accent this start only with
this accent consume resources where
this accent is spoken whatever the
traditional accent is the Mexican accent
whatever the most important thing is that and not to
mix things up
If you are
consuming only the resources of this
accent for a few months, you are going to develop your
linguistic nucleus in this  e accent the accent is not
only a number of sounds it is
also a personality a culture that
represents this country the accent itself and it
is important to develop this
personality later once you have
consumed this you have already developed your
linguistic core your personality and your
accent you can hear  whatever the
traditional accent the Peruvian accent is not going to
change much you know how when you learn
a language your native language in your accent
you can spend I don't know 20 years in another in
another region of your country and it won't change
much
when I speak with Spanish speakers and I
They ask Luca how is it that you speak
Spanish so fluently and sometimes before I would
answer him that I was in Barcelona I spent
a few months five or six months in
Barcelona and that said to me oh well now
I understand but wait a minute in
Barcelona they don't speak Spanish  but
Catalan if you also speak Spanish but
it's not like Madrid and something else at the
university I only listened to the classes in
Catalan and at home I speak  I had a little bit of
Spanish but not much because there
were also two Italians as well as a girl from
Malaga so the truth is
that I didn't learn Spanish in Spain I
learned it in my country in Italy and
also in Paris when I lived with
Spanish speakers for example in Paris
I lived with a roommate from
Barcelona with whom we spoke
Spanish in Rome I have roommates who
had Spanish-speaking roommates
the message is that it is not true that you
only learn if you live in a certain country yes
no
mobiles it is not important where if not
how  the time you spend how you
use it and above all the people you meet
with whom you spend
time with then if Spanish is part
of your daily life with your friends with
movies and so on when you
go to a Spanish-speaking country that goes  to
be the host in the sense that you already
speak the language and you are going to learn even more
as Eduardo says they go with the languages
you are at home anywhere
[Music]
v  Alright here we are so in summary the
first thing you have to know is that
when you start to learn Spanish or
any language in any case it is
important to choose a good resource with
which to develop a linguistic core
the second factor that you have to take
into consideration about  Everything with a
language like Spanish, the process in English,
which are world languages, is that you have
a lot of different accents and that
developing a certain accent means
developing a culture, a way of
being, it's not just an assembly of sounds
in quotes and a third point, you have to
know  that if you are in the usa
if you are in latin america' in italy in
spain russia wherever you are the most
important thing is not where you are but what you
do with your time the people with
whom you spend time discuss talk
enjoy life in general this  It is
what makes the big difference and then if
you practice in your day to day, wherever it
is, if you go to a Spanish-speaking country,
you will  To have a good time as they say in
Madrid
If you want to know more I have written an article
that you can also listen to in English
about how I learned Spanish and the
lessons I have learned
and you just have to click on the link
in the description box description
box below and nothing  Thanks for listening
and see you next time here on
YouTube in Spanish and in other languages
[Music]